history of squabbling over
their ambitions in space.
To understand the rivalry
we have to go back to 2004.
When Musk and Bezos met for a dinner.
According to Christian Davenport’s
book, the Space Barons,
Musk tried to give some tips to the
Amazon CEO about building rockets, saying:
"I actually did my best to give good
advice, which he largely ignored.”
Their space companies were
just start-ups at the time.
Bezos - who has always been infatuated
with space - had the means to start Blue
Origin in 2000 as he was flush with
cash from Amazon. Bezos is so keen,
he recently stepped down as CEO of Amazon
to focus more attention on Blue Origin.
Musk started SpaceX two years later with
the money he made when his company was
sold to PayPal which was then bought by eBay.
They spent the first decade building up
their ventures without a lot of bickering. But
that all changed in 2013.
When SpaceX secured a long-term
lease of launchpad 39A at NASA’s
Kennedy Space Center in Florida where
the Apollo moon missions took off from.
Bezos wasn’t very happy about the deal.
Blue Origin filed a formal protest with
NASA to prevent SpaceX from using it exclusively,
arguing it should be turned into a “commercial
spaceport available to all launch companies."
In reaction, Musk called the protest a "phony
blocking tactic" in an email to SpaceNews
and said SpaceX would accommodate Blue Origin
should their vehicle be launch-ready. But he
couldn’t resist taking a swipe at Blue
Origin’s progress, writing “Frankly,
I think we are more likely to discover
unicorns dancing in the flame duct.”
SpaceX secured a 20-year lease
of the historic launch pad.
The next year, it was SpaceX
that had beef with Blue Origin.
In 2014, the U.S. Patent and
Trademark Office granted Blue
Origin a patent for landing
rocket boosters on drone ships.
This would have meant that SpaceX would
have to pay to use the technology.
SpaceX argued that the concept of drone
ships had been around for decades.
A judge sided with Musk’s firm, forcing Blue
Origin to withdraw most of its patent claims.
Since then, SpaceX has successfully landed
its Falcon 9 boosters on drone ships
66 times to date - the first time was in April
2016 on the ship “Of course I still love you”.
As SpaceX achieved successful launch after
successful launch that year - Bezos tried
to poach SpaceX’s President and COO Gwynne
Shotwell, according to the book Amazon Unbound
by Brad Stone. But Shotwell declined the job
of Blue Origin’s CEO. It would go to Bob Smith.
Musk has had an issue with Blue Origin’s
hiring practices. He told Ashlee Vance who
wrote a biography about him that Blue Origin’s
tactic has been to snag talent away from SpaceX
by offering “double their salaries.” Adding,
“I think it’s unnecessary and a bit rude.”
While SpaceX has sprinted ahead, Blue
Origin has progressed at a far slower pace.
It successfully landed
New Shepard for the first time
in 2015 - after which Bezos tweeted it was
“the rarest of beasts - a used rocket.”
To which Musk pointed out it wasn’t exactly rare.
SpaceX did the same with its prototype
Grasshopper three years before, in 2012.
And Blue Origin still has not gone into orbit.
It carried passengers for the first
time on a sub-orbital flight in July.
Bezos and three crewmates
flew past the Karman line,
the internationally recognized boundary
of space, before returning to Earth.
On the other hand, SpaceX has gone into
orbit with the Falcon 9 over 100 times,
including taking astronauts to
the International Space Station.
Both billionaires have their sights
set on sending people much farther.
When SpaceX beat out Blue Origin to win a
coveted contract with NASA to land the next
humans on the moon using this modified Starship,
Musk joked Bezos ‘can’t get it up’...to orbit!
And speaking of sexual innuendos: Musk also poked
fun at the name of Blue Origin’s lunar lander,
Blue Moon, tweeting: "Putting the word
'Blue' on a ball is questionable branding”.
Blue Origin is suing NASA for awarding
SpaceX that contract worth $2.9 billion.
The government agency originally planned on
investing in two lunar landers going forward.
The choices were SpaceX, Blue Origin,
and Dynetics. However, budget concerns
and a lack of funding from Congress scuttled
those plans – forcing NASA to choose just one.
Blue Origin feels it’s dangerous choosing
only one company, writing in an open letter on its website:
“Competition will prevent any single source
from having insurmountable leverage over NASA.”
And created this infographic
blasting SpaceX’sStarship.
The contract is only for an uncrewed test
flight and the first crewed landing on the moon.
Blue Origin and others can still
bid on further contracts. However,
Blue Origin argues that SpaceX
now has a huge head start.
And after this loss, it lost a lead engineer
who had been working on the lunar lander.
Nitin Arora announced in a LinkedIn
post he was moving over to SpaceX.
Bezos’ other company Amazon also has a problem
with SpaceX’s satellite
internet service, Starlink.
Over a thousand Starlink satellites have
already been launched, serving 90,000
customers worldwide according to SpaceX. The
company aims to launch many thousands more.
However, Amazon has urged the Federal
Communications Commission, the FCC,
to reject SpaceX’s updated plans that call
for two different satellite configurations,
arguing SpaceX should have made these changes
“...before filing its application - not after.”
Why does Amazon care? Because it
plans to launch its own satellite
internet service dubbed Project Kuiper -
which led Musk to call Bezos a “copycat”.
There’s no word on when Amazon’s
service will start operating.
SpaceX responded to Amazon’s protest by calling it
“...a continuation of efforts by the Amazon family of
companies to hinder competitors to compensate for
Amazon’s failure to make progress of its own” and
also noted that Amazon has “lodged objections to
SpaceX on average about every 16 days this year.”
Musk then tweeted: “Filing legal actions against
SpaceX is *actually* (Bezos’) full-time job.”
SpaceX is banking that its
high-speed internet service
will bring in billions of much-needed
dollars to fund the colonization of Mars.
Settling on Mars is not anidea Bezos likes at all.
He’s made veiled comments about Musk’s
plans, once saying that Mount Everest
would be a “garden paradise” compared
to living on the freezing red planet.
He also took a shot at one of the
reasons Musk wants to reside on Mars.
In case Earth were to get destroyed.
Bezos called this kind of backup plan “very
unmotivating” without naming the SpaceX CEO.
On the other hand, Bezos envisions
a universe populated by floating
space colonies that hold a million people,
some of which can resemble our own cities in order
to take the pressure off of Earth’s resources.
But Blue Origin doesn’t have a timeline
to turn his vision into reality,
nor has it discussed how big of a role it
would play in trying to make this happen.
Whereas SpaceX is operating with concrete
goals in mind. Musk has said he’s aiming
to send people to the red planet for
the first time by 2026 on Starship.
It all depends on the rate of
progress of the gigantic launch
vehicle which is under development in south Texas.
SpaceX conducted its first test flight
of the Starship in December 2020,
a huge achievement that even Bezos
acknowledged, posting on Instagram:
"Anybody who knows how hard this stuff
is impressed by today's Starship test.
Big congrats to the whole @SpaceX team.
I'm confident they'll be back at it soon."
Blue Origin is now working on
its own answer to Starship.
New Glenn was originally designed
to have a reusable first stage but
not a reusable upper stage. However, the
company is reportedly working on making
the second stage reusable as well to compete
with Starship which is a fully reusable rocket.
The secretive Blue Origin project
has been code-named “Jarvis”.
When someone on Twitter suggested
that Blue Origin is acting like a kid
copying someone’s homework, Musk
replied with laughing emojis.
New Glenn was supposed to go on
its maiden voyage in late 2021.
That has now been pushed to late 2022.
Blue Origin’s motto is gradatim ferociter which
in Latin means “step by step, ferociously”.
But at its pace so far, Musk
jokingly dismissed the idea
that Blue Origin was a true competitor in
an interview with the BBC a few years ago.
You’re obviously a very competitive person.
You’re competing with the likes of Jeff Bezos
Jeff Who?
And it's likely that this kind of banter will continue.
If you’d like to learn more about
how humans will survive on Mars,
and how our bodies will physically
adapt to the change, there’s a great series
on Curiosity Stream called “Becoming Martian”.
My sponsor Curiosity Stream has documentaries
on everything you're curious about.
One of my favorite shows of
all time is Redesign my Brain
where host Todd Sampson goes through specific
exercises to become smarter and more creative.
So you're gonna see a series of letters flash by
and in the middle of those
letters are going to be numbers.
The task is to remember those numbers.
You saw one. What was the other? Didn't see it. Didn't see it.
Okay, your turn.
There are documentaries on tech,
science, space, and history.
If you head to curiositystream.com/newsthink and
use my discount code: NEWSTHINK, you’ll save 25%
off your membership, so that Curiosity
Stream is only $15 for the entire year.
My custom link is in the description.
Thanks so much for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.